first domino to fall was in jacksonville
where urban meyer was named the head
coach last night and this was a
brilliant move by the jaguars to bigfoot
division around weekend because
why else would we be talking about the
jaguars and the jaguars are now the top
story and they have been for the last 24
hours even though they're not playing in
any of the games this weekend here's
urban meyer on job number one for him
which is drafting the right quarterback
with that first overall selection
and obviously the jaguars do have the
number one overall pick what are your
thoughts on this upcoming quarterback
class and uh is there a separation in
that quarterback class with the top
overall guy
you see trevor you see justin you see
zach you see you know that that this is
going to be you know that as shad said
this is a monumental moment for this
this franchise and we've seen some
franchises explode and we've seen others
fail and and
i've said this many times you know
throughout my career is that when the
nfl says it's a quarterback league you
know i would say well so was college and
so was high school so was pop warner
it's a quarterback sport
so whoever takes that snap is we have
got to be right on
if i didn't know better and i may have
to go listen to this again
i believe shireen that urban meyer has
given us a simsism
i believe he said monumental which is
exactly the kind of thing i expect chris
sims to say on pft live
any weekday morning between seven and
nine a.m eastern but beyond that yes it
is a monumental or monumental whichever
one you choose decision for the jaguars
as to what they do with that first
overall
pick and mike you've talked about this
repeatedly college coaches have not come
into the nfl with great success when you
look at the last six who've been hired
it's matt rule bill o'brien cliff
kingsbury chip kelly doug marone and
greg schiano who came from the college
ranks to the nfl ranks their record is
not sterling as you can imagine 145 179
and one obviously bill o'brien is the
only one of those guys to to have a
winning record in the nfl after coming
from the college ranks now having said
all that urban meyer is way more
qualified than those other guys based on
what he did in college he actually had
great success in college at different
programs unlike those other guys did
when you look at what cliff kingsbury
did at texas tech he was not successful
and we'll see the jury's still out on
his success with the cardinals but mike
that is a huge question and it is a huge
gamble but if you're shot khan and you
look at the other coaches that you've
hired who have not been good who have
not had success marone mike malarkey and
gus bradley this is a good hire for him
and you know why because you're going to
sell tickets you're going to sell
jerseys you are going to sell out that
stadium you have the number one overall
pick which we assume is going to be
trevor lawrence you could sell trevor
lawrence and you could sell urban meyer
for at least two or three years to that
fan base in florida
yeah i agree with you completely and
peter king made a great point today as
it relates to the pressure that will be
on urban meyer at the nfl level and i
haven't thought of it this way but i'm
very familiar with the ohio state fan
base i've got family in columbus and it
is over the top and at the college level
you get one loss
a year before you're out of the running
for the national championship so there's
an expectation every week that they're
going to win and against most teams the
expectation is they're going to win big
with the jaguars you can lose two three
four five six games and still make it to
the playoffs so
maybe there'll be less pressure and
surely there's less expectation the fan
base is far less zealous the fan base
hasn't been spoiled by anything two afc
championship
a three excuse me i forgot about
96 it was 96 99
and 2017. am i missing one shireen i
think that's it right no three afc
championship appearances no super bowl
appearances for the jaguars there isn't
a legacy of greatness and if you're
making the jump to an nfl team
i would pick the team that's never been
in the super bowl i would pick the team
with the fan base that isn't already
demanding something special right away
and you better be 12 and 4 or 13 and 3
and you're not exactly following a tough
act in jacksonville and you get the
first overall pick and you're in a
division that isn't murderers row this
all lines up nicely for urban meyer the
question is can he handle the pressure
of the nfl maybe he can because it is
less pressure than what is foisted upon
the person who's in charge of the ohio
state football program
and it's obvious mike that he's going to
be in charge of personnel they hired him
first before you hire the gm that's what
he's going to do there he's going to
make all those decisions they are
slated to have the most cap space of any
team for next season they have two
number ones two number twos two fourth
round picks this could be a really quick
rebuild i think the two keys are
hiring a good staff you saw jimmy
johnson do that when he came to dallas
he hired a really really
good coaching staff and i think that is
the number one crucial thing for urban
meyer and guys who have nfl experience
if it's scott linehan is offense
coordinator at least he has
nfl experience and nfl experience as a
head coach and the second thing is
getting the quarterback right obviously
you have to have that quarterback jimmy
johnson drafted troy aigma with the
number all one overall pick and it
worked out if trevor lawrence is who
they pick and he works out i think this
is going to be a great success story in
jacksonville for urban meyer
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports